this is a production of Cornell
University
so welcome my name for those of you who
don't know me is Chris smart and I'm the
interim director of the school of
integrative plant science here at
Cornell I'm really excited to be able to
have everyone here today for sips first
mini symposium I hope that we can do
more of these it's really nice at this
mini symposium actually came from the
faculty Alena Adam got a Munya I tried I
had it actually went to a meeting and
came back really inspired about
high-throughput genotyping and she sort
of started sending emails out and I
think by the time I was copied on an
email the thread had about 45 messages
in it of faculty in ships that were all
enthusiastic about high throughput
phenotyping and the many
multidisciplinary activities that could
come from it and and I got copied in
because someone said well you know what
can we do
and can we get funding and and so from
that this mini symposium was developed
and also a white paper that we will use
to try to advance high-throughput
phenotyping here at Cornell one of the
reasons I'm so excited about it is
because of the multidisciplinary aspect
the coolest thing to me about sips is
the breadth of research that we do from
the most basic to the most applied and I
think that the excitement of
high-throughput phenotyping really spans
all of those disciplines you know we
have today someone from the soil and
crop science section and also plant
breeding and genetics and certainly our
breeders our folks in agronomy our
driving forces for high-throughput
phenotyping but as a plant pathologist I
can say that you know we want better
stronger and faster ways to identify the
amount or lack of disease on plants so
it's not it's not exclusive to to those
that don't work on diseases so the other
thing that I wanted to say this morning
was that I'm hoping that from the talks
that we hear today and from the visitors
that we have was so excited to have you
here that many of us will be inspired
and will be able to continue to have
this multidisciplinary dialogue and
we've moved plant science at Cornell
forward but also be able to translate
what we learn here in high throughput
phenotyping into agriculture agriculture
here in New York across the country and
around the world there are lots of lots
of ways that we need to support our
agricultural industry and I think that
this is a really good place to start so
with that I would like to introduce Mike
Gore who is an associate professor of
plant breeding and genetics and he is
going to kick off our morning first
session
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu